let us now give an example of a
continuous random variable the uniform
random variable it is patterned after
the discrete random variable similar to
the discrete case we will have a range
of possible values in the discrete case
these values would be the integers
between a and B in the continuous case
any real number between a and B will be
possible in the discrete case these
values were equally likely in the
continuous case at all points we have
the same height for the probability
density function and as a consequence if
we take two intervals that have the same
length then these two intervals will be
assigned the same probability
intuitively uniform random variables
model the following situation we know
that the numerical value of the random
variable will be between a and B but we
know nothing more we have no reason to
believe that certain locations are more
likely than others and in this sense the
uniform random variable models a
situation of complete ignorance by the
way since probabilities must add to 1
the area of this rectangle must be equal
to 1 and therefore the height of this
rectangle has to be 1 over B minus a so
that we have a height of 1 over B minus
a we have a length of B minus a so the
product of the two which is the area is
equal to 1 finally here is a more
general PDF which is piecewise constant
one thing to notice is that this in
particular tells us that PDFs do not
have to be continuous functions they can
have discontinuities of course for this
to be a legitimate PDF the total area
under the curve which is the sum of the
areas of the rectangles that we have
here must be equal to 1 with a piecewise
constant PDF we can calculate
probabilities of events fairly easily
for example if you wish to find the
probability of this particular interval
which is going to be the area under the
curve that area really
consists of two pieces we find the areas
of these two rectangles add them up and
this gives us the total probability of
this particular interval so at this
point our agenda moving forward will be
twofold first we will introduce some
interesting continuous random variables
we just started with the presentation of
the uniform random variable and then we
will also go over all the concepts and
results that we have developed for
discrete random variables and develop
them again for their continuous
counterparts